you can wear a micro mini with a
oversized sweatshirt and a pair of
sneakers and tap into that athleticism
right a very gentle transition from
sweatpants to micro mini skirts no
problem
[Music]
hello i am elisa kelly resident
astrologer here at the drew barrymore
show and i am zanna roberts rossi and
elisa just gave me the title of resident
style empress which i will take so today
we are going to be looking at some
fashion trends that the stars have in
store for the summer do i say that
quickly
psychedelic prince we're seeing all of
the runways it's hippie of a bygone era
it's like wallpaper prints
is it something you're seeing i'm
obsessed with this because we have
jupiter the planet of expansion which
very much sets the tone for the year
ahead it stays in a sign for about a
year and it is in pisces which is your
zodiac sign of course but it is the sign
that is most associated with that hippie
psychedelic escapism dreamy fantastical
magical sort of ethereal otherworldly
energy so we're seeing this reflected in
the fashion is very much capturing the
spirit of that jupiterian larger than
life sort of almost alice in wonderland
exactly we could also find like great
little tops in the same print and wear
them with a cool jean so you can really
bring it into everyday world instead of
being too like trippy with it i think
that we're going to be seeing a lot of
sort of fantastical magical
um sort of like
dreamy dreamy it's dreamy yeah yeah
micro minis micro minis are back and
apparently we're all going to be wearing
them i'm ready really yes okay this is
fine this is going to be very much a
summer trend is that we have jupiter
moving into aries this year as well so
after jupiter has its time in pisces
that dreamy mystical ethereal sign we're
going to be moving into
very aggressive ambitious competitive
fun spirited athletic
aries so as we shift out of our
sweatpants and into
things like
a very gentle transition from sweatpants
to micro mini skirts no problem
i love the idea of that we can all it i
mean it it's a trickier trend to wear
for sure the runways you're seeing micro
minis and midriff bearing tops like it's
full on out there like as you say aries
aggression like this i am going out to
party but i do think there's a way for
people to wear it at home you can wear a
micro mini with a oversized sweatshirt
and a pair of sneakers and tap into that
athleticism right perfect i would say
micro minis haven't been around since
probably the y2k which was seeing this
like resurgence of our y2k trends right
it's very much about
like the micro minis the sparkles the
midriff bearing tops the matching track
suits there's a very like britney spears
thing happening again in fashion
christina aguilera butterfly sequins
like is that happening in the solar
system as well yep so we are in that
20-year cycle
with our nodes which are the
nodes of fate associated with destiny
and they move in 19-year increments so
we are seeing the same fashion happen
now that we did in 2002
2003 and 2004. that's exactly what's
happening yeah completely i predict that
we are going to see a return to the von
dutch the ed hardy
the the very sequined
dragon motifs are going to be coming
back that sort of like biker chic i
think we all need to buckle up and get
ready for
something i have been trying to forget
for the past 20 years
so it's buckle up literally because
we're going to be seeing the leather
jackets for sure the von dutch hat you
are so right by the way and if i look
into my future fashion knowledge as well
the people that the things that are
trending the the things i know are
coming up in the market
you're absolutely right oh my gosh
it is
out my friend they're back
okay so this kind of my next one
actually is a leap 20 years before this
because we're kind of seeing
this return to
suiting right so it's like that 80s
working girls shoulder pads
a big wide pant like wide strides high
waist
but with a twist
power
boss baller business woman working girl
shoulder pads
a wide leg pant it's all about the wide
strides high waist
wide leg pant
with the with the blazers but the
difference is this time it's kind of
like made a little bit sexier so we're
seeing like little micro tops underneath
a little bit of sparkle thrown in the
mix it's kind of like this boss
let me say that
i think that this is gonna be really
interesting to see because this is also
we were just talking about the pluto
return right and pluto is the planet of
transformation and i think that there is
this collective consciousness
you know we have a lot of people
changing their jobs right now and we're
really towing that line of perception
you know how dress for the job you want
not the one you have and also we've not
been in the office for quite a long time
right and then there is going to be a
return to getting back in the office so
maybe we want to like you say dress for
the job right and how are we going to
look when we get back into the office we
want it to be something that is chopped
yes we want it to be sharp we want it to
be bold we want to actually have a
purpose yeah we do not want any frumpy
maybe we could do tearaway midriff i
heard it first people you heard it here
elisa with the style there we go
valenciaga
well this was eye-opening and slightly
terrifying i am elisa kelly and i will
see you next time wearing a juicy
tracksuit and von dutch hat with a
little coach bag and i'm zanna roberts
rossi and you will catch me here on the
drew show and also at zana rossi i will
not be wearing a psychedelic cat
that's disappointing sorry
[Music]